it's always a dangerous signal when
otherwise reasonable people start
thinking that investment return to the
most interesting thing they could talk
about why don't we pause there for a
moment and let me pick up another theme
that Joannou so introduced and I found
myself commenting on inadvertently and
that is the ways in which the otherwise
decentralized University have may have
been making efforts over recent years to
coordinate more closely as management
team Susan why don't you what do you
start and I i think the Alumni Center is
a great example of that on a couple of
different levels you alluded Jim talked
about the Alumni Center and how that
sort of came to be and it was one of
those I think wonderful confluences of
great partnerships inside the university
and a bit of being in the right place at
the right time because we knew we needed
to move from the inner church center our
lease was coming up and the university
needed to find space for us and you know
we were thinking we might end up in
rented space in midtown or I mean there
were all kinds of possibilities that we
talked about because the fact is we
don't have much space and I think we all
agree that the priority you know we have
to think about faculty and students
first that is after all what the
university is all about it was Joe who
as he was trying to figure out the best
and highest use for the School of Social
Work looking at the neighborhood and all
kinds of other contextual things he had
to deal with I think called Robert and
the Robert called me and I remember
Robert saying would you consider you
know moving into a renovated McVicar and
you know what's going through my mind is
are you kidding you know to move back
into university space having been in
rental space for so long and to you know
the sense of having our own building it
didn't take very long you know to sort
of snap that up and sign the lease or
what she did fake it so she'd get a
better deal
so because one of the things we talked
about early on and one of the things
that we looked at was Joe yeah we had
one of the other things that had been
going on and it some of it had come
through CAA and a lot of it had come
through the Columbia College Board of
Visitors was this profound
disappointment that there was not any
place on campus that really was an
alumni space and no one was expecting
that it was going to be you know some
huge facility or whatever but that there
wasn't you know there wasn't any place
and already we had been talking about
that and then space for the staff and as
we looked at how to how to configure the
space for the staff and we knew we
wanted a much more open environment and
everything else it also meant we had
space we could take the ground floor
area and dedicate that to this what i
would call wonderful first step in
providing in a space for alumni on
campus and joe and his colleagues and
facilities were incredible partners in
helping us work and it it was you know
like building your own house x 20 and a
couple of my colleagues Fred Van Sickle
and Liz Braden spent amazing amounts of
time we got some alumni involved in
taking a look at how we were configuring
the Alumni Center we went and visited
alumni spaces all over the city it was a
wonderful partnership and this would
never have happened if Joe had and
Robert hadn't been committed to the
goals that we had for alumni going
forward yes the president had to be
committed that trustees because they had
to allocate the money for this but no
one would have even had this idea they
wouldn't have even had the opportunity
had it not been for our colleagues who
you know came forward with this so that
i think in one way a great sense within
the university administration that we
really do feel like we have a shared
vision for where the university's going
and that we do work across in a really
great way and jim also mentioned the
fact that
this building we have college and
university alumni and development staff
until very recently engineering was also
there they've now moved back to the
engineering school and although we were
in space together in the inner church
center it was still it was not it was
very undesirable not very attractive and
not commendable to partnership and
working together in the alumni center
it's very different and I think for the
first time have an opportunity to live
out what we've been talking about in
recent years and that is you know more
collaboration and more close working
relationships so on that level as well I
think we've been able to bridge some of
the silos if you will in a really
productive way and I just hope we
continue I've realized how fragile those
things are a lot of it depends on who's
in my job who's in Joe's job who the
deans are at any particular point in
time and everyone needs to share that
continued commitment to the working
together so you know don't assume it's
solved forever I think each generation
of leaders have to recreate it in a way
that's really true